in San Francisco supervisor Dean Preston
is calling for a public hearing to
address the ongoing car break-ins he
believes that the number one solution is
a more robust public awareness campaign
so that tourists understand that they
cannot leave anything in their car
anywhere in the city of San Francisco I
was on a walk so brisk just minding my
business out with my walking stick can't
you see
innocently but I'm just human oh it's
true yes I am just a man what else could
one do seeing Luggage in a minivan I
have no choice in the matter do you not
understand I check it once then I check
it twice ah ooh look what you made me do
look what you made me do look what you
just made me do look what you just made
me do look what you made me do look what
you made me do look what you just made
me do look what you just made me they
don't want to steal whiskey but they
must feed their
family my newborn loves py he's a boy
and he likes blue how do you expect
someone not to shatter all this glass
when he sees this while only carrying
the 14 Max any chance you might step up
to defend property rights I Che it once
then I check it twice H ooh look what I
always do look what I always do just
look at what I like to look at what I
like to do what I always do look what I
always do just look at what I like to
look at what I like to do yeah I'm
looking to
[Music]
move